what up guys welcome to the just really
thinks YouTube channel today I have Ally
hi I wanna I wanna be able to do the
smize like the like so I can't imagine
imagine you're you're a cute guy imagine
imagine
oh no no no no not bad no that's like
okay you're on a roller coaster yeah
it's like I'm showing the excitement
yeah it's something that I've got to
work on I'm definitely two years give me
yours come here mine yeah yeah Tom was
here yeah
um what's your I'm trying to I'm trying
to have sex honey I I don't know I do
that hold on you can't do it you've
splured it okay okay no okay so I'm
actually not that flirtatious of a woman
I've been told my fashion needs more I
feel like the flannel is like it's
Midwest gold I feel like it screams
housewat but I've had complaints
apparently but today Troy's gonna help
us yeah he's gonna help me be a sexy
housewife hopefully because I don't
think I don't think the country chic is
really that hot I'm sorry people think
women have it easy
and we do
[Laughter]
you know it's things get hard I don't
know well I think you have to choose
young if your looks are gonna be of the
utmost importance to you for some reason
I miss that that train but uh in my late
20s I'm like oh you know I should
probably do something so I don't look
ugly oh my gosh that's the one thing
guys like it when you put an effort to
your appearance I looked homeless for
most of my 20s yeah I I looked that
slightly better
but it's like you don't really need
anything to carry you when you're 18.
it's like you could wear you can wear a
brown paper bag and nobody cares
I go back and forth with that because a
lot of guys will say that you know they
don't care that much about a woman's
appearance now looks yes but like
appearance no but anytime I've looked
super tacky I feel like was not the time
that I got lucky with a guy what do you
mean taxi tacky just like not
fashionable looking like a like a bum or
uncoordinated I don't know pick your
poison so they didn't want a red pill
class red pill class
do you think you should start with the
kids and tell them the young women that
it's basically over a third year should
we wait till they hit like 16.
[Music]
we're going to meet with Troy Francis
he's gonna teach us as women how to be
more fashionable apparently I have
there's a gap there
um I was shocked but the audience let me
know and he's gonna teach us how to
flirt yeah I mean I would be I would be
very grateful to Troy because I actually
I don't have any clue how I got married
I think it was just based off of the
jokes and not being fat I feel I think
my husband would say the same so
hopefully I can learn how to be
cokehead-ish you know my shoulders my
strategy is always just being the
general vicinity but I'm still single so
it really doesn't work
my general strategy has been to let men
know that I find them attractive first
because it primed them into being
attracted to you you know it's like
psychological warfare so it's like
tricking them well you know only one in
three and one and five so if you people
that know that you think he's hot I feel
like it's really good for you it's like
do you really think we could turn a hole
into your housework would we shoot for
the stars of this partly thing happens
every day well they do it all the time I
mean I'm not saying they're great
Housewives but some guy out there will
retire I don't support it or condone it
but it's a reality
call me Mr 65 bored and retired you said
I feel like at 60 like I just feel like
over a certain age you just have to give
up
Troy this is this is my apology video to
you
um we are late but you should have
expected as much we are women yeah you
know it's because he didn't come and get
us because if he got us
it's to be on time we're women so we're
in chaos yeah like all the time
dysfunction that's why we need men
friends
sure but you've got like a pie in front
of you I feel like that's a more on the
wholesome side of thrift shop it's still
a thirst trap but at least you're trying
to say like hey I could bake for you in
a Myrtle I I feel like there's like
respectful thirst traffic yeah I don't I
don't do it but it's like
I think you can respectfully bear strap
not in a relationship but like I just
don't think that it's bad for women to
themselves out there like obviously if
it's a
bit but if you
could be there and you meet the guy and
then you pull all the thirst try
pictures down I feel like that's a true
testimony right does that mean think
about it if I was getting noticed good
girls kind of don't well I feel like the
thing is the good girls aren't as hot
that part is not like I mean I'm not
saying it depends right but I'm just
saying like the hoes get no just because
they're hot and it's like this will
happen it'll be like the fives and sixes
will be like oh I don't get noticed like
the hose well they're they're sevens
eights and nines all right seven eight
and nine attention yeah of course they
can notice first I guess I guess we'll
ask the audience you know so is there do
you think that ugly hoes get noticed
more than pretty hoes is what I would
ask wait no of course wait no no okay
okay
ugly hoes over pretty wholesome women
she's a hoe
no no no no if she is hypothetically
grow it's a five six that's not a house
so five six well maybe be there when
he's like 32 and he's like I'm done with
these hoes but for the last 10 years
he's been chasing the eights nines of
tens I think that that is it and then
the girls are like no we don't get
noticed but it's like no he was just
they're they're the hot girls
it looks like that small pool of men but
I think they have to go through yeah I
know they're only ones we see but I
think they have to go through like that
small crazy hoe adventure to be like you
know what I'll take I'll take uglier
nicer I'll take it I think
and but it's just you can't hit the
players you hate the game of course
they're gonna do that they're not
looking for a wife not not early on but
the the same fives and sixes you say
okay do you want to date a guy 10 15
years older they're like no no no no and
I'm like okay well what do you no I feel
like the best yeah I'll wait until this
is done
no I'm telling you is it gonna make it I
mean she she married she married a guy
20 years after 23 but yeah I don't I
don't I don't tell people how to live
their life yeah I'm not telling you what
to do I just look at outcomes like the
the 25 year old dude he's messing with
the hose I don't know what to tell you
well well you know I think Millennials
were just softer so I think like Gen X
Men or personality wise Potter that's my
opinion but I think they had to have
game but my perspective is like one of
the best days of my life is when I
realized that but like older guys were
hot too and that I was allowed to date
them I was like it's a weird it's a
weird phenomenon it's like at 23 24.
yeah I'm like oh my God are the dad's
hot yeah when did that happen I was I
was so confused I was like all of a
sudden these 48 year olds
they just looked old to me and then one
day you're like oh my God yeah I was
upset I had to come to Jesus meeting
because I thought my husband was so fine
but I was like but I'm too young I'm too
young right but then eventually I was
like you know what I don't care anymore
shout out shout out to the 45 year olds
I'm 25 I'm interested just so you know
well if you think about it like if
you're if you're 20s as a man I feel
like you should be but if you're fit in
your 40s as a man it's like that takes
discipline and diligence yeah yeah and
plus they all have jobs oh yeah
25 it's like he could be where you don't
know like I have a startup it's my
SoundCloud rapping Journey
oh
an artist oh okay
45 it's like oh it's a job the only
thing you have to be careful 45 year
olds they may have a couple kids
but you know like uh the younger and
more attractive and kind you are of a
woman you can get like not just a guy
that has a good job but he's also hot
too I feel like this is the problem it's
the five six good girls they're like I
want Africa and a 25 year old I'm like
okay good luck go I'm sorry
to go win the lottery yeah I think all
the JLo movies got to me
what did you
okay good luck
[Music]
tired Chad that's my perspective I could
be wrong it cost me 10 years
I don't know see my parents they met
when they were teenagers but that was a
different time